what else Ranch Dressing is finally
available in kegs good and I'm sure
that'll help with I'm sure that'll help
run up the bill of of insurance cost
that's got to be healthy for somebody
give you a freakin a little nephew a
thermos of ranch dressing kids in fourth
grade sitting there sucking down a
couple of you know pints at Thousand
Island on his during recess unbelievable
just in time for the holiday season
Hidden Valley unveiled their brand-new
ranch dressing keg they say it comes
with a one-year supply of ranch in each
keg Hidden Valley that's what they call
your healthy aortas hidden valleys you
can't even see them anymore because you
had so much damn ranch but you know what
I say that's a good way to go to heaven
if you're gonna die
I've always been ashamed that the only
ways that we have to get to heaven are
or after if you go if you you know or to
deal with the body are embalming or
burning I think is the second one you're
gonna burn me guy
oh that's brave you know you seem like a
smart guy you're burning up people that
are dead what an [ __ ] why don't you
go make a sword and burn down your
neighborhood you freakin sword maker
because here's a thing uh how about this
fill me with [ __ ] ranch baby huh
embalm this little Bobcat
with that RA NCH boo-boo you're telling
me in buck you're telling me that
formaldehyde and that and that and that
being ah what's it called when you're
burnt to a crisp
you know whatever it is decapitated or
something are the only things that can
happen to you after you die no way more
options I want to fill daddy's body with
ranch I want to be in bone with ramps
take my eyeballs out leave my mouth open
put me in the funeral casket all my
orifices open a bunch of little things
chips woo broccoli get them
get them in my faces you know hit them
orifices hit that mouth I I get that
triple dip make me a little bit of a
snack hole that way people are actually
enjoying their time at my funeral am i
showing you know what about bacon wrap
how about you put a huge slab of that
freaking a thick thin ham around daddy's
neck
damn boy have all the dogs barking
outside of that funeral house but you'll
have birds at the window is ready to get
in there and just take a little bit of a
nip nip off daddy's uh freaking head
vase off that neck off that ham
but there's upwe other things you could
do black and dipped baby backed what if
you went to the what if you went to
somebody's funeral and their ribs had
all been cooked and ready to eat and if
you wouldn't have a human rib you're
you're a lying you're a liar and I tell
that I'm you know I'm not saying that to
make fun of eating any of it but if you
wouldn't need a human rib that had been
perfected cooked maybe over there at
Arthur's barbecue or whatever and Kansas
City or in Wichita wherever that place
is you would hit you wouldn't get that
hit huh you can light it you can lie to
yourself just don't lie to me cuz I'm
not listening to it anymore wow you know
it's crazy as my sister can't even read
but what does it have to do with us
right now hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy
two options watch one this one